greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and welcome to this simply learned
webinar today we're gonna talk about how
to increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
best practices for you to take advantage
of to increase Instagram followers so
let's get started and talk a little bit
about Instagram so Instagram is not
really an up-and-coming platform it is
already up and coming a lot of users
fact 500 million daily active Instagram
users 500 million daily a the user base
growth of more than three hundred
percent year-over-year so it's growing
and growing and growing it's become more
and more popular ever since its launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the Instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
100 million photos plus uploaded daily
and then there are 400 million stories
posted daily so when you post something
you can create a story out of it and
there's 400 million of those per day and
then there's more than 50 billion photos
shared to date so since 2010 platform
now which is now owned by Facebook has
become really really popular a good
place for you if you have your own
company if you have your own brand if
you have your own product it's a good
place for you to really showcase that
service that product that brand because
of the user base how easy it is to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story so I mentioned
there lots of photos shared today close
to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through Instagram mobile so on
top of everything I just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here - so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
ecommerce integrated with him the Platt
form so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on Instagram so Instagram is an
ecommerce platform to say the least
in fact Instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're gonna see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
gonna go through some tips and tricks
today and we're gonna talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip 1
here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you can
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram accounts for
example using my desktop I can see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear concise
and compelling bio why because this is
your introduction to the world you want
people to know who you are and because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not gonna follow you so
this is where it all starts you need to
take advantage of your bio have a clear
and concise bio and have a link to your
website or some contact information so
to me this is where it all starts you're
gonna have a bio because
that's what people are gonna look at and
they're gonna decide whether to follow
you or not based on primarily that by oh
that's where it all starts so make sure
you have a good bio that's tip number
one so you have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most Instagram users are on mobile
so if you're going to put a link to your
website and somebody's on the Instagram
app and they see your bio and they like
it and you have a link to your website
make sure that landing page they go to
is mobile optimized so tip number two
everything you do on Instagram when it
comes to posting evolves around hashtags
so that's the backbone of the platform
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like Twitter or
Facebook Pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
Instagram is no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtags so hashtags
are there to help users find your
content so you want to start out by
using hashtags that are relevant to your
business so if you're in the food
industry you're gonna post something
related to food do the appropriate
amount of research to find hashtags to
describe your brand and also or being
searched on Instagram so what does that
mean that means do a little bit of
homework on Instagram you know see what
searches or see what other brands in
your industry are using for hashtags
don't be afraid to use the same hashtag
but mix it up hashtags are important so
don't be afraid to put a hashtag in
there that really defines what your
business is about but if it's relevant
use other hashtags that are popular or
people are using to find information so
mix it up but the key here is relevancy
you want to make sure you align your
hashtags with your content and making
sure the connection between the hashtag
and the content is relevancy so using
the popular tags on your photos or
videos might get you some immediate
engagement but it may not help with
future goals like long term engagement
new interested fires and sales so here
really what I'm trying to say is look
pick and choose your hashtags carefully
because if you use something broad or
something non relevant yeah
you may get that click to your Instagram
page but that doesn't necessarily mean
somebody's gonna follow you or that
doesn't mean it really mean somebody's
gonna be interested in what you have to
offer so if you use something really
popular and broad yes is you're gonna
get short-term gratification but not
long-term interest tip number three post
your content at the right time so
according to sprout social which is a
social media scheduling platform among
other things so they deal with a lot of
people using their platform and posting
content via their platform they have
data and they're telling us based on the
data they've collected that the best
time to post this between 2:00 and 3:00
p.m. and the best data post is Thursday
now that may be all fine and true
according to a sprout social study and
so you may want to go with this 2:00 to
3:00 p.m. and this is probably local in
case you're wondering what timezone or
to referring to so this is all local to
you so go ahead and try that out try 2
to 3 p.m. on Thursday the thing is what
you're gonna have to do eventually is
figure out what the best time to post is
okay so if you're putting out a lot of
content and you're putting out content
throughout the week at certain times of
the day or throughout the day you're
gonna have to determine which time of
day in what day is generating the best
engagement for you who is looking at
your post at what point of the day what
day of the week and so you're gonna
really have to lean on a social media
platform to help you determine that
because they're gonna have the data that
you need to determine what the best time
of day to post is okay so we'll talk
about social media platforms here
shortly
we just know that when you post post
with some rationale in mind ask yourself
before you even push that publish button
or if before you even schedule that post
this time of day in this day of the week
makes sense so you always want to post
at the right time because you could be
missing your audience so remember when
you do this you're going to be working
with some platform and Instagram also
has some analytic
for business accounts so Instagram will
also give you some feedback as to how
your post to perform it and we're gonna
talk about that here shortly as well so
let's move over to tip four here so
steel followers from your competitors
okay so if you're dealing in a very
competitive industry and your
competitors have a lot of followers it's
very very easy to see who's following
them so the easiest way to do this is
just interact with your competitors
followers you could follow a user like
or comment on their photos and so the
more you engage with people the more you
stand to gain from them so you could see
who your competitors followers are and
you can add them as a follower just by
following them so start engaging with
them if they're liking your competitors
brand and what the chance of them like
in your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted they engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to gain followers so when we're on
Instagram we can simply just click on
the brand's followers so here I can see
the Sprint has 127 followers in here I
can see all the followers and what I
could do is simply just click on one of
the followers and I can go to their
profile and from there I can see what
they've posted in terms of videos and
images and I can like or comment so just
doing something as simple as this get
you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip 5 pay for sponsored
post and product reviews so when number
of ways you could do this here so pay
for a sponsored post so you can find an
inflow or so that satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them
ask them for sponsored post pricing so
it's as simple as that is reaching out
to somebody who has a large following
and so if you do this then it's gonna
put you in front of a large number of
people and so by doing this it'll help
expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address and their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
post you want to get yourself out there
in front of people this is the quickest
way to do that okay so tip six we want
to use geo tags for easier
discoverability so Tiger images videos
or stories by tagging the location city
or venue where it was posted from so
very easy to do as you're posting just
go ahead and and there's an option in
there to say hey where you located or
what city are you located in so
locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
gonna be great and it's good for local
businesses because if you're local and
you're posting your location then again
somebody in that location is likely to
engage with you tip 7 use Instagram
stories to attract followers and grow
your user base so stories a really big
feature on Instagram so what stories
could be used for is just show vent
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
couldn't be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you want to show vintage
up so you want to post new relevant to
your industry so if you're in the food
industry hey why not go in the back into
the kitchen and post a story about how a
particular bread
cake is made okay show off your products
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an Instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
story you want to show something unique
and relevant that's going to grasp
people's attention you can promote a
company event so if you're celebrating
say 200,000 subscribers creative YouTube
video or you can create an Instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog post you can
post positive user reviews so these are
all features of a story increase
interactivity with poles sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout-out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have on creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below
so we want to get everybody involved
here because there's a thousands upon
thousands of great Instagram stories out
there to be shown and viewed and engaged
with so go ahead and share your
Instagram story if you have any other
tips or tricks then go ahead and put
those in the comment section so that
everybody can benefit from them so the
only thing to keep in mind when you're
creating these stories is what are your
followers interested in seeing so your
stories could teacher promote something
to your user base so always keep that in
the back of your mind
you know for me I always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you or interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that Pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number a highlight important stories
so you want to highlight highlight serve
as the easiest way to create a first
impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your contents about
create a trailer for what your brand
offers promote and promote your product
highlights are there it's a good feature
it's a first impression for potential
follower so it teases what the contents
about it creates a trailer so to speak
for your brand and promote your product
so use highlights and again any users
out there who have good examples of
highlights go ahead and put those in the
content section or comments section
right below this video
so remember stories have only a twenty
four hour life span so highlights can be
used to give them a second wind
okay so highlights serve a purpose it
teases what the contents about it
promotes the product and it really kind
of accentuates that story tip number
nine asks for followers so sometimes
people need a little push before they
can follow you on Instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers and the caption
the comment section even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know I got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post you know
really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engages then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if it is
popular then go ahead and say hey this
is a popular post you know think about
following me or put something in the
comment section you want to do it kind
of succinctly you don't want to be
begging we're just working in to some
degree okay but don't be afraid to have
some confidence and asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on YouTube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's on
YouTube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on Instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and said hey you like this you know
go ahead and follow us
it's that simple so tip number 10 take
on the latest trends to get more
followers so align your content to cater
to trending topics or hashtags to
improve engagement and discoverability
so really what we're trying to say
here's your competitors follow
influencer
sirs what are the latest trends and you
can get an idea the latest trends by
looking at hashtags so what hashtags are
trending which ones are people using the
most so really what you want to do is
whatever is trending in your industry
you know ride that wave so to speak now
it doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two posts if something is really
taking on popularity then go ahead and
post about it as well you know for
example in the wine industry if there's
a new wine that really came out that's
really gaining some popularity go ahead
and post about it with the same hashtag
and with the unique hashtag so don't be
afraid to you know ride the wave of
popularity so to speak because it shows
that you know you know what you're
talking about it adds some credibility
and it's gonna get some you know viewers
over to your Instagram profile so keep
in mind you need to keep your content
relevant because if your audience is
interesting what you have to offer then
they're going to be engaged however you
know if you're joining the discussion in
a relevant manner keeping in mind
whether your audience whether act or not
is important but just always keep in
mind you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience tip number 11 run contests and
giveaways and so just like on YouTube
just like I'm Facebook I mean the
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contest and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza for their experience and any other
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
could just do something for fun
especially if you have a lot of
followers if you have a lot of followers
and somebody's going to take
in it so don't be afraid to run contest
just to make it fun and light it up a
little bit so each tag can bring you a
new audience member who could be a
potential follower so anytime you run a
contest people are gonna tag their
friends to let them know about that
contest so those friends are gonna come
over and likely engage so that's the
beauty of running a contest or a
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread it's gonna get you some new
followers so that's the the end benefit
so to speak but the real benefit is
keeping your audience engaged so tip
number 12 we want to stay consistent
with posts so having a consistent pace
and theme for your posts can have a huge
impact convert visitors so when we say
consistent you know if you're again that
pizza parlor stay within pizza you could
branch out a little maybe and talk about
salads or talk about beverages too you
know as a complementary factor to the
pizza okay but don't talk about
hamburgers if you're focused in on pizza
so we wanted to stay consistent with
your theme this method involves less
effort with a faster production of
Instagram content so they mean what
we're really trying to say here is focus
stay focused on who you are if you do
that if you're consistent and you're
gaining some followers and that's what
people are coming to you for the content
that you're good at for the industry
you're in okay so if you start varying
it and branching out then it's gonna
muddy the waters suppose so to speak and
you're probably gonna get less
engagement so set it themed on Instagram
by maintaining consistency and your
personality filters colors and layout
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and that kind of
lowers your your personality a bit so if
you stay consistent with in jeans and
outfits that go with jeans then I think
people are gonna start to pick up on
that personality so tip 13 keep
of your Instagram following so you can
analyze the growth of your channel with
tools like social blade I can tell you
how many followers you lost over time
and how engaged they are okay so you can
use data gather from here and from
Instagram business account to diagnose
where your faltering so let's take a
look at social blade as an example here
so if I go over here I'm gonna go to
social blade here I can enter in
basically any account after a register
and I could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on one industry and
the beauty here is I could see and I'm
looking at YouTube as an example I can
see you know how my post to perform well
you could do this for Instagram you
could do it for Facebook so you can
really get an idea of how your accounts
performing so social blade is a great
platform for measuring and again you do
also have Instagram business insights so
with Instagram business insights
basically what you're going to do is
you're gonna go to your app right and
then from the app you could basically
look at your insights from there so in
the app itself you're going to click on
the upper-right three lines and from
there you're going to see insights and
when you go to insights you're also
gonna see you know what your Reach is
how many impressions and some engagement
metrics terms of your audience where
they're located the age range okay
you'll also see some content related
information so there's a lot you can see
from the the Instagram insights
analytics insights but you can also see
additional information from social
Blaine so the key here is when you're
looking at your data you want to look
for patterns and post what posts receive
the most amount of engagement so if you
see something work and obviously
replicated you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you're gonna run videos
carousel slideshows stories so we met
this on other webinars for Facebook
advertising it's worth repeating so if I
go back in to say Facebook Ads manager I
can pick and choose my placements and
really what I want to do is pick and
choose for example Instagram and so I
have Instagram feed and I have Instagram
stories so and I could see with the
video requirement or the media
requirement is for running on Instagram
so with Instagram you can run stories
you can run videos single image ads you
can run carousel - really you could put
your best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're gonna run this through Facebook
Ads manager and it's gonna tell you you
know what your audience size is your
potential reach okay what your daily
results would be so you're gonna get all
that information when you run your ads
on Facebook Ads manager but it's a great
opportunity for you to really push
forward you're running a promotion it's
really an opportunity for you to push
forward that promotion other advantages
scalable pricing self-serve an instant
robust reporting and highly refined
audience retargeting so all of that is
in the Facebook Ads manager you can get
all the reporting yes you need meaning
you know who saw the ad do they click on
it okay you can refine that target
audience you can go back into Facebook
Ads manager and refine who your
audiences so lots effects ability here
and advertising on Instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on Instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15 so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done you
want to minimize the amount of text so
let the image do the talking you want to
ensure your caption relates to the image
and res
with your audience okay so you have an
opportunity to add some text below the
image okay so make sure it resonates and
then of course use hashtags to show your
ads to target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to eat a webpage
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
Instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on Instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good Instagram a
profile here about pizza you know I'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg Pizza consumers I mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if I'm in the pizza industry I
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so some
really good shots of pizza here looks
like you know a lot of people were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
Pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and how
with you know with an example like pizza
just to give you some ideas so let's
move on to tip 16 take advantage of
Instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later HootSuite
and buffer so I can't stress this enough
you know what comes to measuring the
engagement of your Instagram post you're
definitely gonna need a social media
tool so you're also gonna need it if you
do a lot of you know posting on
Instagram so let's take a look at an
example we'll use later comm so if I go
to later here I can see you know I can
use this to upload my images to my
profile so here you can see it's
scheduled throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping
you know we're scheduling based on the
times of the day that people are gonna
look at this so you know here I could
see you know particular stories if any
stories are posted okay I can look at it
from them weekly or monthly preview I
could see what's been posted okay and
more importantly as a schedule 2 I can
also see the analytics I can see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing I want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again I can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags this become a particular
company is using on Instagram so here
you can see how many posts with this
hashtag you know and what in kind of
engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job
I like this platform especially for
Instagram it's great for scheduling but
more important you know in addition to
the Instagram analytics you can really
lean on you know this particular
platform to get a really good idea
- you know how a particular post or
performing remember if a post is
performing you want to reuse it at a
certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown in here and later calm
so remember these tools place an
emphasis on automation okay and they
baleen you to automatically post at a
scheduled time so you want to lock it in
at a certain period of time and I have
to worry about it so it allows you to
really hone in on that particular time
of the day and day of the week so that
you're really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement develop your own
signature styles to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just
coming back to our pizza example lots of
good photos of pizza and where this is
their style this is who they are you
know they're not a particular brand
they're just your people who like pizza
okay and they're having fun with it
okay so that's their style you know
they're posting really good shots of all
this different types of pizza different
styles different toppings just to give
you an idea of how popular pizza is and
what you can do with it okay so yeah
this is a good basic example of what you
can do with something as simple as pizza
so don't be afraid to experiment you
know try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about Instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so I just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to learn from
what's working and not working so
user-generated content shows off your
brand to be authentic and improves your
relationship with your followers so you
know you want to be unique with the
content in your posting so if you do
that you're likely to build that
relationship and
you know increase your followers and you
want to be able to see of that
user-generated content that UGC which is
performing which is not performing okay
so basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working to take advantage of
that remember going back to hashtags you
could set up your own unique hashtag and
ask your users to post images or videos
relating to that which you can post in
your brand's account so just like the
whole pizza thing they're saying hey
look you know use daily pizza for a
feature okay that's a good example of
something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on YouTube
just like on Facebook Instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original I mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality I
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
cuz it really is gonna take away from
you know the story you're trying to tell
so you don't have to be professional per
se just make sure what you're posting
whether it be video or whether it be an
image is of high quality and remember
videos needs to be fun and informational
without causing the user to lose
interest so you know if you're gonna
create a video you know go ahead and you
know maybe you can make it short make it
fun okay you can see here these guys are
just showing you how pizzas made doesn't
take a long time they're just going
through the motions they're not boring
you with details they're not talking
just to give you an idea it doesn't have
to be as serious it could be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating
don't use stock images on Instagram
because you know they don't really bode
well for your particular brand you know
you its Instagram it allows you to post
original content that's the whole
purpose of it okay and on the video side
be concise high-quality and
informational enough okay so you have to
hold the users attention here so when we
say concise you know don't make it a
five-minute video obviously make it high
quality relevant to what you're trying
to offer and if you could do that you're
likely gonna hold the users attention so
tip 20 promote your Instagram page and
other social media channels so Facebook
and Instagram are part of the same
family so this seems like a natural but
you know don't be afraid to promote it
on other channels like Pinterest or
YouTube the whole idea is to get users
to your Instagram page and encourage
them to follow it so you know you can
always put that URL in you know other
platforms like YouTube nothing wrong
with that at all okay you can also
promote your page offline with print ads
and during other relevant events and
then I would even take this to further
as you probably see you know an
Instagram logo on a web page along with
other social media icons so you always
want to help promote Instagram on your
web page as well but you can do it for
offline with print ads so you can simply
just put you know whatever your your
slug is for Instagram whatever your ID
is whatever you're using on Instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online okay so
we want to thank you for you know paying
attention to the webinar hopefully you
contribute with some comments below the
video and if you have any other tips
that you'd like to share it go ahead and
add them to the comments section we'd
love to hear from you we love to share
what you have to say
and so thank you so much for
participating if you have any more
information please visit simply learn
comm thank you hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here